in exactly 73 days MCU blockbuster
Avengers and game will start in the
cinemas until then new information about
the eagerly awaited Avengers will appear
bit by bit one of them will please many
fans in an interview the directors Joe
and Anthony Russo confirmed that the
film could be the longest of the MCU
with the current editing time of about
three hours the similar assumption was
already made in December but it's now
finally official at the moment the test
screenings are in progress which have
produced very positive reactions from
the audience regarding to the length of
the film Russo says that it was quite
difficult to shoot a film that should be
the crowning ending of a total of 22
films after all you have to have
emotional scenes for the characters in
addition to the exciting storytelling
also Chris Pratt aka star-lord was
recently asked about endgame in a talk
show and has put it very clearly in a
nutshell Avengers keeps everything his
predecessor promised and much more many
of you will probably still remember the
3d hype that James Cameron's Avatar
costs in cinemas worldwide in 2009 many
don't even have sequels of the first
part in mind any more however in the
past 10 years a lot has happened behind
the scenes in the meantime Cameron has
conceived and written four sequels two
of them have already been finished
filming and are currently undergoing
extensive post-production similar to
2009 Cameron intends to set new
standards with the sequels he has kill
developed a new type of motion capture
process which was primarily designed for
underwater filming therefore it's no
surprise that avatar 2 will play in the
underwater world of Pandora
what will also surprise many is that
they are working on seeing the upcoming
Avatar movies in 3d without glasses so a
lot has happened behind the scenes in
terms of the cast it will mostly consist
of familiar faces such as ex-soldier
Jake Sully and his Navi lover the cast
will be joined by Oscar winner Kate
Winslet and Game of Thrones star Oona
Chaplin
only the release date will disappoint
some fans as Avatar 2 is scheduled for
December 17th
than 20 and avatar 3 for December 16
2021 whether the two sequels average of
4 & 5 will be shot will depend solely on
the success of the first two sequels
says Cameron children of the 80s in
particular should now listen carefully
after to live-action linea trills movies
by Michael Bay a completely new Netflix
oh Ninja Turtles animation film should
now be released according to the
deadline magazine Netflix has closed the
deal with Nickelodeon and according to
this deal u.s. channel Nickelodeon will
produce an animated Ninja Turtles movie
which will be released exclusively by
Netflix the content will seamlessly
follow the 2018 series the rise of the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
it is not known yet when a release will
be possible but we will keep you
informed about further news of the
pizza-eating turtles after this enabled
entertainment giant Fox many fans
doubted if and how the future of our
rated movies would look like due to its
quarterly report isn't in now commented
on this topic in the future the Marvel
label will also denounce unconventional
action-packed films CEO Bob Iger even
went so far as to say that films like
Deadpool should be the best example for
future adult films they just don't want
the difference between the popular
Disney children's films and the Marvel
blockbusters to be invisible the
production of guardians of the galaxy 3
has been on ice for more than half a
year now one of the main reasons for
sure is the dismissal of James Kent who
now works for DC on the Suicide Squad
after all he had already finished the
script for the third part in an
interview with the US magazine variety
this week lead actor Chris Pratt premise
that there would be a third film however
he did not know any other details a
rather disappointing statement for all
fans who have been waiting for almost
two years for a third part of the
trilogy franchise
moreover they're also looking for a
capable director
we'll bring the trilogy to a dignified
end Adam McKay among others who has
recently received very good reviews on
the international stage with the comedy
film wise is also under discussion after
all there are still many problems to be
solved behind the scenes of guardians of
the galaxy because so far
everything that comes from the Marvel
team is nothing but empty premises the
zombie drama The Walking Dead will
receive a tenth season at the latest
since season 8 and the death of fan
favorite Carl Grimes the ratings and
continuously the fans simply want more
concordance to The Walking Dead comics
in which Carl doesn't die by the way
also season 9 was even less watched in
season 8 despite the announcement of big
changes for comparison while five years
ago there were 16 million viewers today
the figure is only 6 million Andrew
Lincoln aka Rick Grimes also dropped out
in season 9 to the annoyance of many
fans another break with the comic
template so why am see has announced the
10th season for October is not at all
clear to many fans but she can be
curious what the second half of season 9
which will be released on February 11th
will bring and whether season 10 will
make it even worse in October this year
[Music]